so let's just take a closer look at
Lebanon's current political system the
country is governed by a power-sharing
agreement known as the taifa courts it
was designed after the end of the civil
war to redistribute power so the number
of seats in parliament is equally split
between Christians and Muslims the
President must be a Christian and the
parliament speaker a Shia the prime
minister must be Sydney so the current
system has been challenged in recent
weeks by hundreds of thousands of
protesters who say it's riddled with
corruption
let's bring in Marwan Bashara he's out
Jazeera senior political analyst he's
joining us from London but one so the
tie off Accord is credited with ending
the civil war in Lebanon yet many say it
is really the basis of all the problems
it is the basis of sectarianism where
politicians work to benefit their sect
rather than work for the benefit of the
country so one of their demands is to
dismantle the system how challenging
though is that going to be well yes this
is the generation that came after the
taifa cord of 1989 that was 30 years ago
their courts were perhaps necessary
perhaps not but perhaps necessary you
know that in the war and for the
fighting factions within the country to
have some peace but 30 years later
clearly a new generation of Lebanese
wants something else doesn't want sex to
divide the pi's among them they want a
state of citizens within the country and
that's why I think the idea of a
government of technocrats
a good first first step because a lot of
the nepotism and the corruption goes
through the the the ministries that are
dividing the pies among them they are
hiring their own people sometimes their
own will co-religionists and they are
the ones who are giving out investments
and contracts and so on and so forth to
those who are closer to them so the idea
that that's that the state has been
divided among the sect's could could
start diminishing with more of a
government of a technocratic but that's
only a very very first step Lebanon is
going to need far more radical far more
deep changes in order for that sectarian
regime to change into something better
and this idea of a technocratic
government how does it actually work
going forward now that you have the
Prime Minister's resignation what
happens then because we have seen the
president for example oppose this idea
of a technocratic government absolutely
because they know that their source of
power is the government the the the the
president and his son-in-law just like
Hezbollah and other sectarian leaders
within the country do understand that
state power is somehow trickles down to
their own because they have since 1989
divided the pie amongst themselves as
various political parties based on
sectarian allegiances and so in a sense
the Hezbollah and the president have
stood against radical change within the
government because they like the
existing regime because the existing
regime serves their interest and that's
why looking forward you know there could
be some optimism that 13 days later the
government has fell but there's a lot of
work needs to be done because reform and
a country like Lebanon is going to have
to be slow and patient and any radical
change that might lead to violence could
end up diminishing the entire optimism
that we face today so dealing with the
power centers in the country notably
Hezbollah and the presidency is going to
have to be quite meticulous and quite
patient are the protesters though
willing to deal with this slowly and
patiently well it remains to be seen for
the time being I mean they've been
actually one of the more industrious and
wonderful I must had uprisings out there
and they are abhorred it reminds me of
the early days of the Egyptian
revolution very very positive very you
know gay as they say in French very open
and of the you know with the only the
Lebanese flags out there not sectarian
flags not
religious flags not some II you know
smaller identities so it seems like the
various new generations of Lebanese from
the various religions have united along
or around the Lebanese identity at last
and they see that as their way forward
so the problem with it is is that that
they know what they want and they know
that what they're against but they have
not articulated their vision and a
common United leadership for the street
one that could in fact negotiate one
that could in fact run for elections on
so and so forth so for the time being
the best goal their best possible way
forward is to continue the pressure on
the existing regime to reform itself and
to open the way for more fair election
law for more independent judiciary and
for a technic Technorati of technocrats
that allows that kind of mechanism to
move forward and how do you see the
protesters maintaining that pressure
we've seen them out on the streets for
thirteen days but earlier a couple of
hours ago there was talk that the
security forces might try to break up
the roadblocks because people do need to
get to shops and people need to get back
to their jobs so what are the protesters
do next well is there a strategy well we
don't know as I said of a united
leadership for the street and it's been
improvising for all for a long while now
and it's improvisation is both a source
of strength and weakness unfortunately
for the street
meaning the various people from the
various parts of the society is that the
opposition to them from the from the
sectarian least notably from Hezbollah
and the president's party is that they
are well-organized and in in the case of
Hezbollah also supported regionally by
Iran and others and they do have a
program and they consider any change for
the status quo as one that is a Western
conspiracy against Lebanon and that is
very unfortunate of course but but those
and Hezbollah and the presidency do
consider any fundamental change called
upon by the street to be a conspiracy
and hence I'm afraid as they did today
earlier when a bunch of thugs went into
the street and started to break you know
various protests that this might
continue in different ways despite the
fact that the head of Hezbollah in his
last speech asked his followers from
Hezbollah to clear out of the public
squares and yet apparently apparently
secretly or or or implicitly they're
sending out those thugs in order or
there's activists let me call them so I
don't sound tutorial izing in any which
way the activists of the various groups
that Hezbollah are going down the
streets and one of the worst case
scenarios in Lebanon if as Hezbollah
leader said will be one Street against
another Street we've seen that after the
assassination of Rafik Hariri between
the so-called March 7 and March 14
movement that paralyzed the country we
don't want to see the Lebanese don't
want to see in Lebanon paralyzed it want
to see it moving forward so certainly it
wants to avoid at every possible cost a
street against the street a street
against an organized political party
that does not want change in Lebanon all
right Marwan Bashara thank you